voilà d'interminables mois depuis
lesquels les commerces jugés non
essentiels sont contraints de fermer
leurs portes au public
parmi eux on retrouve bien entendu les
restaurants qui après de confinement une
succession de couvre-feu sont au bout du
rouleau il saute dans lequel on nous tue
et de mettre dès 2002 leur grade à vue
si les restaurateurs ont toujours le
droit de faire de la vente à emporter
cette situation est loin de combler le
manque à gagner conséquent que cette
pandémie fait peser sur des milliers de
commerces et où je joue bien certains
pensent même qu'il vaut mieux rester
fermés que d'ouvrir et de perdre de
l'argent
le restaurateur xavier denamur est avec
nous pour nous parler de son combat et
témoigner de la réalité du quotidien de
milliers de restaurateurs en france
merci xavier denamur d'être là à bayda
il a ramené des petits les petits trucs
là à boire ça va ça va gouverner ça va
ils soient civiles merci d'être là
xavier vous êtes restaurateur est
propriétaire de plusieurs restaurants
on se rappelle que stéphane qui est là
avait appelé à la révolution
la semaine dernière enfin cette semaine
d'ailleurs c'était notamment on il a
reparlé sur son plat sur son plateau
vous vous pensez que les restaurants
doivent rester fermés oui je pense que
pour l'instant dans dans vu l'état de
l'épidémie il est préférable de rester
ferme et puisqu'on est accompagné ce qui
n'était pas le cas encore une fois au
mois d'octobre parce que je suis
intervenu à plusieurs reprises dans dans
les médias et j'ai écrit des textes pour
demander un meilleur soutien à l'étagé
même jeu j'ai même écrit à madame borne
à monsieur le maire et on a ces aides
aujourd'hui donc on peut 80 je dirais
100 % des restaurateurs sont couverts
par les aides et ces aides permettent à
80 % des restaurateurs de s'en sortir
effectivement il ya des trous dans la
raquette et on a qui ont plus de
difficultés est ce que dans ces pays dès
cette période de crise et ce qui
effectivement il y aura forcément des
gens qui vont y perdre des plumes si
alors appel à la révolution des
restaurateurs est ce que vous trouvez
que stéphane va trop loin vous vous
trouvez que stéphane et cc c'est trop
alors la révolution j'ai pas compris si
sa révolution des restaurateurs des
chroniques qui dont celle révolution
parce que la révolte non alors qu'il
doit pour ouvrir quoi qu'il en soit
voilà c'était un petit peu le geste de
bravoure de stéphane il a été voilà il
ya plein de gens qui l'ont rejoint sur
ses idées d'ailleurs lundi quand il est
venu nous voir ya plein de gens qui ont
été d'accord avec lui
vous n'êtes pas d'accord avec ça non
parce que moi je suis légaliste et je
pense que dans le dans la période
actuelle je crois que s'il ya une
solidarité et l'intérêt général qui doit
primer on doit pour le moment
effectivement resté fermé parce que de
devenir même si on était ouvert on ne
peut pas financièrement tenir moi j'ai
essayé j'étais ouvert au mois de mai
donc pour faire de la vente à emporter
et sert à ça marchait pas parmi eux pas
génial on a fait aussi de la vente à
emporter
pendant le couvre-feu c'était une
catastrophe et donc quand on a des
petites affaires comme des gros si vous
faites avec contenu on a des joueurs qui
sont divisés par deux et en plus des
couvre feux dont vous faites moins 60 -
70 % occidentaux ont passé qu'il vaut
mieux fermer à tenir vous perdez plus
d'argent en étant ouvert qu'en été
enfermé en plus vous participez à cette
je dirais non pas à l'effort national
contre la lutte contre le virus mais
finalement vous participez à faire en
sorte que ça risque du
et encore plus longtemps stéphane est ce
que vous répondez oui dix réponses au
point de vue je comprends ce que tu dis
a pas de problème à mon sens il ya des
gens qui ont meilleur temps restées
fermées pourquoi parce que les petites
structures qui sont pas adaptés à vers
la vae ou qui sont pas adaptés tout
court et qui ont des petits moyens et
qui sont pas forcément quand on les 2 3
4 par structure on peut encore sortir
avec 10000 par mois c'est pas de souci
les structures comme la mienne ou dans
chaque restaurant les 15 et qu' il ya
tout un faux problème c'est que si les
frais fixes
je sais ce que c'est c'est pas le souci
mais moi un moment donné je dis ça c'est
pas assez pour des structures comme la
vienne pour les petites structures
peut-être après un moment donné je ne
fais pas la révolution
d'accord je demanderai au gouvernement
de me donner une date de réouverture
alors justement vous vous êtes où vous
trouvez que le gouvernement c'est bien
de gueuler contre le gouvernement vous
dites mais quand on a besoin d'être mais
il faut aussi savoir reconnaître quand
celle ci est satisfaisant oui c'est à
dire encore une fois j'étais le premier
à demander parce qu'il y avait une
rupture d'égalité quand paris en prison
ferme et marseille en disant qu'ils
avaient il n'y avait pas les les études
qu'il fallait rouvrir marseille ce
qu'ils ont fait après j'étais le premier
à dire que il y avait des protocoles
quand on les suit et ben on doit rester
ouvert mais aujourd'hui les études
montrent que on est on fait partie donc
des études qui sont sortis d'un acteur
qui sont sortis dans beaucoup de dents
beaucoup de revues scientifiques
montrent que l'on fait partie des
endroits où on peut lever le virus
circule beaucoup et donc je vous vous
êtes d'accord avec la décision du
gouvernement là aujourd'hui oui je suis
d'accord avec est aujourd'hui avec les
décisions du gouvernement et je pense
qu'encore une fois les restaurateurs qui
disent qu'ils sont pas suffisamment aidé
il ya deux soucis soir je sais pas
stéphane ce que j'ai entendu sur bfm ce
matin et donc ils disaient qu'ils
avaient avant qu'un salarié mais qu'ils
en aient distancié 12 en cdd
la cdu c'est la date en soit il n'ya pas
licencier on a fait une fin de contrat
alors on fait des fins de contrats sur
des cdd on explique que attend
d'ailleurs moment donné quand tu as une
structure qui coûte cher d'accord parce
que moi j'ai une triste elle s'est
située une grosse station d'épuration
chez moi pour traiter les eaux sûres
après on a tout on a deux chaudières toi
c'est tous ces frais qui coûte cher la
toiture qui a été à réparer une poignée
d investissement faire donc moi ce que
je dis c'est pas c'est pas le problème
de l'aide en soit c'est c'est
l'immobilisme de l'état c'est ce qui me
dérange de plus avant je t'explique un
moment donné je veux
que nous prendre de l'argent de l'état
ça me dérange pas franchement je veux
bien regarder netflix avec moi j'ai une
ourse moi ça me dérange pas je te jure
ça ne dérange pas fous moi je suis dans
mon canapé c'est bien l'avouer nickel
sauf que cet argent-là amende année on
devrait donner à d'autres parce que à
d'autres plus en difficulté nous il fait
moins 10 dehors du temps il ya des mecs
sont dors et club de froid mais nous ça
ne nous dérange pas de dire ça nous
restaurateurs alors que nous on est en
capacité de travailler ça te dérange pas
de dire ça abandonnée nathan jeudi
charité bien ordonnée commence toujours
par semaine ça là dessus je suis
d'accord avec toi par contre faut pas
oublier les autres sur le bord de la
route parce que mon nous reprochera nous
restaurateurs d'avoir ponctionné
l'argent de l'état sans en faire
profiter les autres
alors tu peux dire ce que tu veux
l'atuge suis pas d'accord avec toi alors
encore une fois si je peux répondre et
la question n'est pas de ponctionner ou
de vivre subtil de l'état et on fait
quoi aujourd'hui à l'état demandé l'état
nous a demandé et nous demande de rester
fermés comme le suspect comme les les
salles de spectacles etc
donc il nous accompagne le temps qu'on
soit fermée pour pas empirer parce que
si on se retrouver en angleterre ils
sont fermés jusqu'au mois de mars
donc l'idée encore une fois ses dettes
c'est pas grave d'être ferme et donnez
nous une date en août à malcom a
aujourd'hui dans l'état actuel mais même
séquence il a donné les dates alors si
si vous êtes tous voient ainsi tuer et
piller épistémologue moi je veux bien
mais je pense pas qu'on l'aide aux
cadets des gens qui sont tirons d'aidé
qui sont au niveau de la médecine etc
qui regarde toi un conseil scientifique
de concept juridique dit que c'est très
bon il dit que le jour le restaurant et
ils peuvent pas en l'état actuel on
s'est donné une date c'est clair et non
initiés là encore une fois à chaque fois
en 2001 date qui sont dans l'incapacité
c'est pour ça que ils vont tantôt
temporisé donc pour l'instant on est
aidé ils nous disent on verra on aura
une date de revoyure 10 février en
fonction de l'épidémie mais ça pourra
durer jusqu'en mars voir moi-même je
pense même en mai parce qu'on pourra
rouvrir nom n'est fait avec les
terrasses mais comment ils vont faire il
ya plein de restaurateurs quand vous
entendez plein de restaurateurs qui dit
on n'en peut plus on va mettre la clé
sous la porte on va faire mais ça va il
ya vingt ans de travail qui vont s'en
qui va s'envoler en fumée
qu'est ce que vous leur répondez que
j'ai j'ai montré j'ai démontré sur dans
une tribune sur l'obs plusieurs
structures j'ai un groupe où il ya
quatre entreprises qui font plus de 6000
ont-ils affaire est une petite
entreprise qui fait moins d'un demi
million de chiffre d'affaires lorsque
vous avez une petite structure l on
était très mal aidé en mars avril mai
puis le mois d'octobre et surtout
novembre on a dix mille euros quand vous
avez une petite structure ses 10000
euros vous suffisent largement puisqu'il
couvre votre perte même bodji d'affaires
si vous faisiez même dix mille euros de
chiffre d'affaires
le gouvernement vous donne dix mille
euros quand vous avez des structures
plus grandes ça va jusqu'à 200 leur a
donné on va voir elle sophie koch je
sais que vous étiez très énervé le lundi
quand vous entendez xavier mais vous
savez ce qui met en fait hors de moi
finalement c'est qu'on suive comme ça
comme des photos et ce genre de discours
c'est fabuleux parce que vous êtes en
train de dire
alors moi finalement je suis assisté je
m'en sort très bien et c'est bon je
respecte le protocole c'est génial
évidemment que le but est l'idée c'est
de respecter le protocole évidemment que
le but ce n'est pas de créer des
clusters dans les restant évidemment que
le but ce n'est pas de créer des foyers
où va se développer de grands navires us
mais l'autre problème c'est que
aujourd'hui quand même vous entendez
même une partie de la population toute
une frange de la population qui ne s'en
sort pas c'est pas du désespoir c'est de
l'agonie et à un moment donné il faut
entendre ça aussi contents les les aides
pour ces gens là a comme dans les
hôpitaux non mais alors par un discours
avait sais quoi d'autre j'ai pas dis
alors quelle est ta solution ce film
expansion c'est un moment donné apporter
des solutions qui sont probantes à des
gens qui en ont besoin
certes on ne peut pas regarder par
exemple stéphane quand il est venu
témoigner mardi dernier on lui demande
alors aux stéphanois vous allez tenir
combien de temps encore avant de mêlée
c'est adéquat moi je suis obligée de
retarder le jour donc mais on n'écoute
pas ces gens là c'est à dire qu'on en a
à [ __ ] en fait comment ça se passait
et les rues du mal à compter qu'on a
tellement de choses on ait du mal à
comprendre déjà stéphane parce qu'il est
fermé j'ai entendu ce matin sur bfm
il est fermé décembre et janvier donc
normalement suivi d'autres zones y est
oui d'accord et deux mois il est ferme
et ensuite car si on laisse couler
aujourd'hui si vous rouvrez les
restaurants comme vous dites sans aide
et vous c'est resteront là au lieu de
pouvoir tenir jusqu'à une réouverture
normale vont couler c'est tous deux
sortent de cette des centaines des
milliers de salariés qui vont être à la
porte maintenant dont vous allait
empirer
le phénomène mais alors j'en voulais le
voler évidemment qu'à plein de petits
restaurateurs ou même des restaurateurs
plus importants qu'ils ne peuvent pas
ouverts parce que effectivement ce
serait à perte donc ça c'est ridicule
mais qu'on leur laisse le choix s'ils
peuvent ouvrir aujourd'hui en disant
voilà on respecte le protocole qu'on
mette des inspecteurs sanitaires qui
disent oui ou non voilà c'est respecter
et vous pouvez ouvrir alors ça leur
permettrait de survivre
c'était pas des mecs que je fais pas de
toi toi je suis dit qu'il serait moi
je vais y arriver dans l'absolu je
comprends ce que tu dis hein y'a du
surendetté au fait je vous ai pas bien
il a raison sur certaines choses bien
sûr j'ai des bonnes qu'il a tort
c'est je suis allé vous m'avez quand je
suis venu je suis allé dans un hôtel qui
que la production avait m'avait pris un
tu vois le hôtel où j'étais très bel
hôtel très sympathique
une personne à l'accueil tu commandait
depuis la chambre le repas tu aller
chercher tu payes et surmonté avec l ua
qui fait lui un travail et pourtant ils
font à manger alors tant pis t'as un
choix de cartes de 5,10 plein il a bien
étudié
c'est tellement vrai toi y'a plein de
plein de restaurants et de chaud comme
ça surtout sur les hôtels bien sûr
qu'ils devraient prendre exemple parce
qu'ils ont continué sur le petit
déjeuner et repas du midi et du soir
mais on peut toujours organisée et
qu'elle met des choses près ce qui se
passe est un auteur est juste j'ai
l'impression que vous avez un groupe
vous c'est un groupe de restaurer c'est
ça ouais ouais il faut qu'elle soit
divisée sur un peu ce que 10,6 millions
et voilà vous fait 100 millions c'est
certain mais j'en ai une 206 ou non mais
vous avez d'accord il avait d'abord que
vous avez des comptables un avocat
taillage pense que les demandes ont été
faites en bonne et due forme je pensais
à ce qui a été fait pour prendre toutes
les caves et apprendre moi je pense
effectivement que dans le cas de
certains alors c'est prêt ou d'un peu de
ce qu'on veut c'est que ces deux ces
voix là c'est pour tout le monde pareil
c'est vrai qu'à seront des gens a pour
qui c'est plus grave en tout cas même
entendre que dans certains cas et dans
son cas lui qui n'a pas un groupe qui
n'a pas inscrit un seder de siméo ce que
vous savez ça c'est pas dix mille balles
cela peut vous être y 200000 oui lui lui
s'est dit me dont c'est pas l'heure pas
lâcher alors je vais répondre parce
qu'il existe un vrai beau de zoug foschi
gala ici des choses absolument fausses
qui sont petites failles et déjà quand
on avait donc tout les petites
entreprises étaient les seuls qui
étaient aidés jusqu'au mois de décembre
puisque j'ai gueulé puisque à l'époque
nous avons rien toucher des moments on
avait plus de 50 salariés
on a eu zéro et le moment vous faisiez
plus d'un million de chiffre d'affaires
vous aviez 0 donc ils ont eu dix mille
euros les petites entreprises ont été
les plus aidés et les groupes moi c'est
un groupe c'est ses cinq petites
affaires qui ont une cinquantaine de
salariés dont vous vous servez
après on a eu 20 % qu'on n'a toujours
pas touché c'est là que si on lis sur
l'année moi j'ai perdu six cent mille
euros ça depuis si on lis sur l'année ça
représente passé mais ça nous permet aux
salariés aujourd'hui dont j'ai 54
salariés
ça nous permet de lisser sur l'année
mais ça ne rattrape pas mais ça ne
rattrape pas je le dis millions de jeux
vge et c'est encore une fois c'est pour
éviter parce que si j'avais pas lu maman
femme sur neuf harris en aliénant sa
touche encore et encore une fois vous
vous trompez ça ne fait pas de
trésorerie
ça permet de payer les tice et ça permet
de trésorerie ça permet simplement de
payer les loyers les frais fixes
la comptabilité que ça ça me permet
juste d'attendre parce que si on
attendait pas et que ce soit moi ou des
plus grands goût c'est pour ça que
monsieur bruno le maire a dit qu'il
allait même augmenté de 200 mille ans je
touche pas 200 milles mais chose 110000
parce que c'est 20 % de mon chiffre
d'affaires sur un mois je répète bien
ces trois mois de référence et un mois
de référence à faucher et donc oui
monsieur pour ces quatre clair a dit
qu'il allait progresser le montant de
cette allocation parce que effectivement
y'a pas de raison que les grands groupes
il ya pas d avoir une rupture d'égalité
et que ces grands groupes vont finir par
couler parce que si on effectivement la
prix dp je moi j'ai aussi en détail d'un
million d'euros j'avais déjà deux
millions de crédits donc le problème du
monde aux orties on va le problème c'est
que c'est sur des mots aux basses et ça
comme ça est ce que vous allez ouvrir
vote resteront pas sans autorisation moi
alors je la salue février tu peux venir
il ya pas de problème on a créé un
collectif aujourd'hui
et puis on n'est déjà pas loin de 200
restaurants
ouais bref leur ouvrir en même temps au
jour ben non mais attends c'est si tu
veux on vous allez ouvrir le premier
fait venir et on va ouvrir alors moi
personnellement ça va être compliqué
mais ce qui veut dire beaucoup de monde
j'ai l'énergie
les rg sur le dos après fait du loup ils
m'ont dit fait hein c'est pas le souci 1
devrait pouvoir après bien sûr que je
vais être amendé bien sûr que je vais
prendre des risques d'accord vous avez
occupé ou pas pendant un mois je vais
ouvrir quoi qu'il arrive on va le faire
dans une norme bien particulière sauf et
six gouvernements aujourd'hui me dit ok
on va vous donner un cadre et un
calendrier
c'est juste que ce ne sera pas le 20
janvier donc aujourd'hui on avait
compris mais tu crois qu'ils avaient
tous 15 février
non moi j'étais chez monsieur pascal
praud soit alors il m'a dit comptait pas
avant septembre
d'accord lui dit pas avant septembre cet
homme je pense dit on
des cas c'est ce que vous avez mieux à
faire parce qu'il dit au mieux ça sera
joint au mieux au mieux ce sera donc
après tu vois les laissons touch c'est
le tueur la même problématique sous le
plancher mars
si on vous dit de voir ces 1er mars mais
a dit que si j'arrête ou moi on me
croyait pas trop d'accord vous pourrez
pas le 1er février banon mais c'est pas
la peine d'accord mais du coup tu
attends excuse moi mais faut arrêter un
moment de dire des bêtises ne vont pas
annoncer la le 20 janvier le tout basé
sur ils vont annoncer que le 15 février
pour moi est ce qu'ils n'ont pas de
visibilité le 1er février
ce concept est ouvert ce 1er février
tu mets en danger tel salarié tu met en
danger les clients parce que tu es hors
la loi se rappelle quand même que il ya
des gags et gary code pénal dans ce pays
et que en tant qu'employeur tu risques
non pas simplement une amende
tu risques aussi un an de prison 15
mille euros d'amendé s'il faut s'opposer
à la question toi tu voudrais pas la
question de savoir où ce et les petits
dans tout ça mais les petits j'espère
que tu te poses pas avec le temps c'est
simon qui fait 6 millions d'euros
excusez moi je vais bien je comprends ce
que tu dis aimer risque chez les miens
les prend pas c'est pas les 13 fait dans
l'immobilisme ça me dérange pas d'accord
si de toi ça te convient de prendre les
dix mille balles par mois et prend un
centime et le bal par mois sans essayer
de te battre au moins d'essayer de
pousser au cul pour dire on reprend s'il
vous plaît parce qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a
même pas un ministre à temps chaud c'est
quand même extraordinaire dans ce pays
il ya un ministre de la culture
d'accord mais pas de nice tourisme non
y'a pas l'historie c'est un secrétaire
ouais secrétaire d'état a déclaré le
ministre je suis désolé donc à qui tu
dresses pour avoir un bout de ça ils
vont en prendre deux pour en faire un
donc moi je vais aller jusqu'au bout de
mon idée je suis pas fou je vais pas
mettre les gens en danger si tu imagines
si bien 5000 chez moe s'ouvrir le 1er
février
ouais on va ouvrir le 1er février dans
un autre format pourquoi parce que je
peux pas accueillir tout le monde qui
veut bien d'accord le deal c'est quoi
c'est de faire une grande marche
silencieuse
ok pour aller à la guerre avec les gens
on va faire un petit gueuleton dans les
barques et de friture est un morceau de
saucisson aux costauds comté de chez
nous un morceau de paea machault
d'accord et puis on va on va offrir
formule halal ou casher grâce à ses
importantes allaient d'une à des trucs
d'accord
c'est de faire un grand à grand grand
grand promenade en ensemble si j'ai fait
ça c'est pas pour mettre les gens en
danger c'est pour avoir un coup
médiatique pour qu'on parle un peu nous
qu'on nous aide parce que à un moment
donné c'est toujours mais grande écoute
les cgi qui sont en train de crever
c'est moi qui sont obligés de faire des
cagnottes clichy [ __ ] de merde mais
vous êtes sérieux
nous voulons donc est ce que vous
pourriez aller faire ça marche je vois
pas là je vois pas l'intérêt je vois
c'est un bolide révolution non mais il
parle de révolution c'est une évolution
pas une révolution
les révolutions déjà on écrit des textes
des gens qu'on fait des révolutions
prokop on parle de bistrot il y avait
monté ce que y'avait voltaire c'est au
poteau ils ont préparé la révolte
l'achat des rois étonné dans une
démocratie on est légaliste on n'est pas
légaliste moi je considère
qu'aujourd'hui l'état a mis sur la table
suffisamment pour le contribuable et
ariane les huit ans et détient encore
une fois c'est l'écart mais si c'est que
si céline dabel et a encore une fois
c'est la collectivité a mis suffisamment
d'argent soit 1
si les mecs qui font du black n'ont pas
assez pognon parce qu'ils font trop dit
la vérité
encore une fois je ferai tout ce qui est
dans ce que l'état belge en temps il ya
20% il ya des gens qui disent on n'a pas
touché on a des bras l'état dit depuis
le début
monsieur macron comme les ministres ont
dit si vous aviez des différends et des
arriérés avec le fisc vous ne pouvez pas
attendre du fils qui vous rendent
restitue de l'argent dans d'autres pays
à l'angleterre dans d'autres pays comme
l'angleterre
vous avez vous n'êtes et dès que si vous
payez des impôts on n'est pas dans ce
pays on est ce que vous avez
je venais
ce que je connais un peu le dossier il a
un groupe i les salahi l'épée d'etzella
gros salaire tous les mois vous avez un
gros cerfs tous les mois qui est
toujours de travailler avec avec bien
sûr un showman à 80% est venu expliquer
un mec qui est qu'un bébé de s'emballer
mais qu'il est qui et qui rendent qui
est surendetté cas pas de salaire sinon
passez sur le temps il a pas d'odeur je
vous trouve pas solidaire java
sympathique banon narre ciel encore une
fois battre la question après un film
tout cas je pense que sa situation est
beaucoup plus confortable que la sienne
- alors quand vous parlez il a vous avez
parlé de 2,2 voilà deux d'argent liquide
les restaurants c'est la vérité ça ce
n'est pas de tout et à s'accepter c'est
pas bien en parler ah ben c'est pas bien
des choses c'est que c'est non c'est pas
dit que c'est d'en parler dit comme on
est dans cette période de crise dit pas
que les mecs leurs fonds sont les fonds
de tiroirs entre guillemets pour pouvoir
vivre et qu' il avait comment faire plus
quelque part tu vois c'est pas bien ce
que tu dis non attends c'est encore une
fois et enfin des fois tu fais pas appel
au pge non mais moi je lis juste eut
publié son bilan est ce que tu montes et
j'assume moi je suis abattu mais bien
parce que j'ai pas bu sol et sur les
tendances et j'ai acheté ma bière
on a fait un ado mais non parce que j'ai
vu que tu avais tu avais une boîte il ya
quelques années ma vie privée
on a on a des documents
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on n'est pas les
mêmes d'une parce que moi j'ai acheté la
maison j'ai eut fait des travaux et j'ai
payé le fonds de commerce l'année
dernière dernière
alors c'est pas faux mais tant que tu
existes alors on va déjà quand même
temps non mes skis mais moi je me
démerde tout seul à oser dire sur une
chaîne que je un que je ne travaillais
pas que deux jeux profitent du système
ben oui tu as fait le tri sont
sceptiques
ça fait trente on est moins d'aisance à
42 ans je travaille j'ai milité contre
la baisse de la tva j'ai milité pour
annie et sèvres je suis venu sur ce
plateau pour migrer parce que le séisme
était mal foutu dans l'intérêt général
non j'ai pas dit que les dvd chômage ces
classes ont elles vu aujourd'hui la 13e
position elle est mauvaise mais toi
c'était le côté conte proverbe ont tiré
le groupe accor répondait jeudi jusqu'à
abandonner
on n'est pas tous dans la même catégorie
je suis d'accord avec toi il ya certain
que ça arrange et tu as raison pour
protéger les salariés
pour certaines entreprises il est mieux
ne pas travailler mais c'est sûr pour
des mecs comme moi c'est pas possible il
faut que j'ai même source pour des
clients aussi mais il ya plein de
petites entreprises qui vont rester sur
le carreau parce que oui il ya une
mauvaise gestion pour certaines cela
cornes d'accord oui et désinvestit
vancouver je viens d'acheter un deuxième
resto juste avant que vie de merde
j'avais pas vu venir cela n'avait pas vu
venir je fais venir investir et la série
mais comme j'ai dit on a fait des petits
sauts la [ __ ] je rachète un autre
souffle toujours faire mario [ __ ]
c'est pas possible
mais qu'est ce que je vais faire quoi m
mais mettons en place ce total
investisseur sais de quoi je parle je
tiens à dire que je vous aurais dû
répondre
encore une fois il ya des gens
effectivement qui rouvert des restos et
je comprends il ya alors on parlait que
ce soit des gens couverts moi j'ai un
collègue au côté converse au mois
d'octobre ont effectivement y'a pas
effectivement il n'ya pas deux il n'y a
pas de d'historique dans leur chiffre
d'affaires pour pouvoir être soutenus
c'est très compliqué ayrault on parle
des saisonniers ou tout à l'heure du
parler de ces décès d'aider les gens
c'est dd tu avais pas besoin de rares
était le cds des enfants ici seuls cdd
s'arrêter il s'arrêtait oui il servir la
maison le chômage partiel parce que
encore une fois le gouvernement pour
tous les saisonniers a poursuivi a fait
poursuivre je la fais pour suivre le
chômage partiel sasia pas un pays au
monde où on n'aura été autant soutenu
par l'état c'est l'arrêté on a râlé
j'étais le chemin des personnes premier
j'écris j'écris à madame bornes par
exemple à propos des congés payés parce
que je rappelle quand même que notre
travail et les amène l'angle ma demie de
travail cumule les cheminots les congés
payés pendant le chômage partiel
j'aimerais y cumule aussi des jours
fériés garantis ce à dire que les
restaurateurs aujourd'hui moi je vais
devoir en fin de course de voir
quasiment et j'en ai mis une semaine que
parce que l'état nous a permis de
remettre leur a posé une semaine au mois
de janvier on va avoir la plupart si on
leur a pas donné la semaine de congés
payés
xavier à des gens qui savaient que
j'avais jamais convient d'adopter tandis
que maintenant durée que l'on va
clôturer là dessus mais c'est tout comme
si tu fais couler ses pilotes
dimanche à midi qu'il ya plein de petits
restaurateurs sur des petites affaires
qui sont bons points qui n'en peuvent
plus est-ce que vous pouvez les
comprendre parce qu'on vous dit que
aurait comme ils vont faire mais encore
une fois ci il faudrait dire y'en a
plein qui ont fermé ou regard des
chiffres alors qu'il y en a plein qui
ont failli confirmer déjà pas tant que
ça parce que si on regarde nos impôts
2011 2020 ont été beaucoup moins
nombreux qu'en 2019 pourquoi parce que
il ya cpg l'eau il ya ces aides les
petits encore une fois ci sont dans les
clous par rapport à leur bilan les aides
actuelles couvre plus que ce qu'ils ont
besoin encore une fois il faut regarder
avec les loyers etc
quand tu touches compter une petite
boîte que tu fais peut-être cent mille
deux cent mille euros tu as dix mille
euros par mois c'est à dire quasiment
l'équivalent de son chiffre d'affaires
et n'a pas de sanary est rien il savait
c'est pas de dire je suis dit tiens pas
non mais ces abats cycle des justes vis
des réseaux de l'ouvrir maintenant vous
procure ou demande si par solidarité
vous auriez faire une marche silencieuse
avec un masque ce tacle mais personne en
danger
pour soutenir les gens qui font
exactement le même métier de vous mais
qui sont à la gorge vous dites non
j'irai pas et il ya une petite querelle
or en revanche il ya douze chefs qui a
aussi une chronique une tribune dans le
figaro en dix ans on a un soutien et ça
commence par guy savoy on soutient les
petits restaurateurs c'est bien que vous
le fassiez pas javier c'est euh c'est
quoi juste parce qu'il ya plein de
questions
diageo qui disent qu'il a prononcée
daucourt de xavier court parce qu'il y
en a pas un blanc var où il n'y en a
peut-être trop dans la république
tchèque née dans le sac web est ce que
ça sur les réseaux sociaux tous les
goûts
encore une fois les fêtes terminées web
j'ai toujours écrit j'ai écris parce que
moi je travail allégé texte j'écris des
textes effectivement allé très vite j'ai
écrit des tribunes
j'écris des textes j'envoie des manises
et séverine de guy ça m'a aidé pour
aider encore une fois pour aider les
restaurateurs et tout l'ensemble des
restaurateurs à verser textes ont été
finis par être entendu que ce soit par
monsieur bruno le maire et sa non même
on ne connaît dans le secteur pour aider
tous mes collègues en permanence c'est
pas parce que tu m'as faire une manif
que tu vas faire une pétition que ça va
faire aider les choses et pour les gens
décide des jambes il est si bas des gens
qui décident sont dans les ministères
les gens qui décident
on regarde les chiffres regardes ses
données mais valérie bercy sa ceinture
voilà comment l'état doit gouverner
merci stéphane on va 7 rebonds ses
téléspectateurs tiens est ce que
stéphane est alors oui 37% de nom à 63%
douaniers stéphane vous avez c'est vrai
qu'on a fait un petit sondage même dans
la rue c'est vrai que les gens qui est
plutôt d'accord avec vous donc vous
allez réouvrir le 1er février
ouais d'accord très bien et ben voilà
donc qui voit là ça faisait je l'avais
pas fait changer d'avis je gérais voir
si le 1er février s'est ouvert selon les
règles et ses lois apparemment tout cas
c'est celle également servi un coup
d'oeil du côté des galaxies pas ce qui
ce qui me débecte ses bords des mecs
comme toi qui es jeune et puis qui
profite de l'argent public d'après ce
qu'il veut faire la vraie leçon à moi
poursuit-il publiques chez msi de ses
fils avait jusque là mais autre idée est
encore dense et à la mêlée pendant des
années merci plus d'impôts dans ce
milieu
encore une fois les richesses